Pareto charts are a different way of
representing frequency distributions in
order to help us understand particular
kinds of effects and what's important
and that's really important that's
really vital to understand this is all
about understanding what's important in
a situation can we rank this in some
sort of way and make good decisions off
the basis of it so let me give you an
example of this okay suppose what you're
looking at is just the sales numbers for
a particular like shopping center or
something like that
based on what day of the week that it is
okay so these are you know 1,000 2,000
3,000 all the way up to $10,000 sold in
that day it's not a massive shot but you
know it's making some O'Kane money and
you can see that they've got this
distribution based on what day it is
okay now hopefully you notice there are
some obvious patterns here for example
there are two days which sort of stand
out among the rest Saturday Sunday why
do you think anyone want to forward a
theory why might the weekend attract
more money so via the demographics are
who's going there okay good okay so not
only a Monday to Friday it's a school
week but it's also just for most people
it's a working week right so people are
at their day job can't be other shops
spending money is that okay it makes
sense okay there's another spike on
there what do you mean that's not
Thursday Thursday late night shopping
okay so shops are open a bit longer and
they do that for this exact purpose so
that people can get there okay get it so
here's what we're going to do remember I
said to you a Pareto chart is about
taking some data and working out what's
important here's the first step I've got
this other copy of this graph which is
slightly different as you can see the
first thing we're going to do is take
this same data and instead of doing it
in a chronological order it's not the
only order we could do it in I want us
to put the same data onto here what
we're going to rank it we're gonna rank
it right so we're gonna start from the
left with the highest data point so in
this case would be Saturday which is up
there at 8:00 then we're going to do the
next data point so we're going to do it
completely out of order and there will
be some that are the same and that's
fine but we're looking for a sort of you
know cascading graph here that shows
which are the biggest days all the way
down to the smallest is can I
give you a minute you can pick your pen
back up now to go ahead and put those
onto the chart hopefully you can still
read it but is that okay for you
acceptable you can continue doing it
while I talk through this let me explain
now that we've done step one place this
same data set in descending order let me
explain what we're going to do next now
I did mention this set of axis is a bit
different because really there's a
second vertical axis what's that guy
doing there and that's kind of the thing
that makes a Pareto chart a Pareto chart
you've got the thousands of dollars of
stuff sold you still get days in the
week here but look there's our color
this are the vertical axis is a new
thing altogether
it's our cumulative frequency percentage
cumulative frequency percentage so the
reason why I chose one to ten is just to
make this next bit a bit easier for us
I'm gonna have a cumulative frequency
sort of adding up all the way to a
hundred percent that's the entire group
of people okay so this scale over here
will be like 10 percent 20 percent 30
percent all the way up to a hundred
percent okay so go ahead label what this
is put a few of the things on this so
you know what's what this is about 20 30
40 50 now dude if me okay now in order
to actually put this next part of a
dollar on well I need to know what the
cumulative frequency is and then I need
to convert that into a percentage so
that takes a bit of thinking to get a
percentage just like with the two-way
tables I need to know what any of these
numbers are in comparison to the whole
which in this case is a week okay now
you can see there's a day that's 8 and
then 7 and then 4 can anyone go ahead
and in fact not anyone can you all go
ahead and help me work out where's the
total number of sales in thousands of
dollars over the course of the entire
week you go ahead and you calculate it
for it
you get apparent what was it here 25 can
we double check can we get some
confirmation is a 25 or 26 25 it's
almost like I planned this okay now
$25,000 okay now what we're then gonna
do is take this this figure and we're
going to use it as our denominator each
time we work out the percentage or I
should say the cumulative frequency of
each of these so we'll just start it off
step by step sound look at the first one
okay yeah it's a - it's a - it's a -
yeah it's mentally sorry it's not the
most accurate okay
so let's work out our cumulative
frequency percentage keep in mind we've
reordered this okay
the first one is the easiest $8,000 sold
on a Saturday and I would compare that
to the total sales so that's 25,000
right so if I say for Saturday the
cumulative frequency just the first one
is 8,000 so the cumulative frequency
percentage will be 8,000 divided by the
total sales over the whole week
what percentage is that it's 32% 32%
okay now because we've got this bar
graph on here already right and I don't
want to confuse what I'm about to draw
on to you with the existing data I'm
going to take these figures and I'm
going to draw them on a bit differently
so 32% there's 10 there's 20 there's 30
so it's just above the 3 here so 32% I'm
going to mark with a big fat dot on the
first column because that's Saturday the
first data point and then we continue
now to work out cumulative frequency do
you remember think back to our frequency
distribution tables you have this data
point plus all the previous ones right
so this data points 7000 and then you
add on all the previous ones which in
this case is 8,000 so what I get 7,000
plus 8,000
that's 15,000 that's my cumulative
frequency at this point total sales and
then I divide by my total just like I
did before is it 60% 60% fantastic okay
so now I'm on to my Sunday call and I'm
all the way up to 60% I'm gonna put a
big fat dot there just like a human see
cumulative frequency polygons before
this is going to keep on getting bigger
and bigger because it includes all the
previous ones with it